hello everyone
and welcome to another youtube video
now a couple of videos ago i did a
series where i did a chess.com
puzzle rush survival run uh and i
divided that into three parts what i did
was i
went through a series of puzzles of
increasing difficulty
and i explained my solutions step by
step from
what i saw when i first looked at the
position to the thought process that led
me to the solution
that series was very well received now i
thought about continuing it but
the problems that we we had reached are
already of such a high level that
it would be a little bit impractical for
me to do it in a video and make it
accessible to everybody in instructive
so
what i decided to do in lieu of that is
a video where i basically solve five or
six
problems um in the rating range between
approximately 2200 to 2400 which
is a rating range of puzzles that um
you know a lot of people have told me
they struggle with so they're able to
solve problems you know the 2000 level
but when it gets to this master level a
lot of the problems stop a lot of
players
and i'm basically going to apply the
exact same approach i'm going to go
through approximately five of these
puzzles
and i'm going to explain step by step
the process that leads me to solving
them
um and and hopefully while i'm at it
share some advice about
finding tactics in general because we're
doing all of this for the sake of
practical improvement
um the one thing i wanted to remind you
of is that if you do have a
board lying around some of these puzzles
are very involved and they feature
long variations so it's important
if you want to follow along to reproduce
every puzzle on your board
and while i will try to make things very
clear and easy to follow
sometimes the lines are long and you're
welcome to make those moves on the board
without further ado notice that i'm
using chest.com fantastic learning
feature
to categorize the problems and frame
them within my desired rating range
let us let us begin now
we have a position here what can we
observe immediately about it
we have basically a bunch of pieces
masked on the king side black has just
played f6
a move with a pawn in front of his king
which by definition
weakens the position of his king let's
try to take that a little bit further
how does it weaken the position
of his king well it does weaken the a2
g8 diagonal
right can we exploit that well i noticed
this queen actually i can't play quinn
a2 check
okay so that is a check there is nothing
effective to block that diagonal with
remember there's two fundamental ways to
defend against check you can intercept
the check
or you can move the king that's a decent
well you can capture the piece that's
giving the check but
hopefully you don't do too much to that
so the king has to move to h8
and here i noticed that the k18 has no
way back the queen is guarding the g8
square so if we open up the h file
that's going to be checkmate we can go
rook h3 so a lot of people i know will
be tempted by knight f7 check
but the issue there is he's not going to
go into smother made he's going to take
that knight
and remember white's king is also very
exposed so
that's that doesn't look like any good
now what we can do
after queen a2 king h8 is actually give
a check with a knight on g6
ooh and that does exactly what we wanted
to it opens up the h
file and we can deliver the checkmate on
h3 with the rook so
the key here is that i asked myself how
his last move
weakened the king specifically rather
than just saying it weakened it
i say how does it weaken it well it
opens up the diagonal
can i exploit the diagonal yes i can
here we have another situation of a very
very weak king
and again rather than getting
overwhelmed let's try to decompose
the sort of individual elements that
that we can black skin now there's three
things i immediately noticed first of
all
we have a bunch of pieces staring at the
king right we have the bishop we have
the knight we have the queen
that tells me that potentially we can
sacrifice one of these pieces
and still have enough material left over
to give checkmate
the other thing i noticed is that
there's this pawn on f7 that's pinned by
the bishop which means the g6 square
is actually accessible to white's queen
um so
should i want to i can give a check on
g6 we'll get we'll get right back to
that in a moment
the third thing i notice is that we have
a queen and a knight in the attack queen
and a knight is basically the most
fearsome tandem in all of chess um
i think jose ro capoblanca early world
champion from cuba was
don't quote me on this but i think he
was the first to sort of draw attention
to the fact
that the queen and the knight are
incredibly fearsome
very very strong attackers that can
produce a lot of mating patterns so
with that in mind the move knight g5
comes to immediate mind but
the problem there is it doesn't create a
threat and the reason it doesn't create
a threat is because this
dastardly knight on f6 is guarding the
h7 square
so black can simply take our beloved
bishop on b3 and we run out of fuel
so let's shift from that to considering
checks captures and threats which we
really have to do here i mentioned that
that is a very elementary piece
of advice but it actually is a very
powerful one if and
only if you don't try to do any
self-selection and you literally look at
all of the checks within reasonable
limits i'm not saying queen h7 is
something you have to consider
for a very long time okay so
the first move is of course queen g6
jack that seems very tempting especially
because of king f8 we take on f7 with
checkmate
the problem is he goes to h8 and if we
try to
dial you know pedal backward with queen
h6 then he can even block the check with
his knight
and it seems that we've actually done
more harm than good because his queen
can now jump out to f6
not good what else is there well there's
bishop takes f7 check now it might seem
counterproductive to give our bishop up
for a pawn that's pinned anyway
but let's see what happens if he does
that because what i see is that if king
takes f7
then we can actually bring the knight to
g5 with check
okay the king has two possible retreat
squares he's got king e7
if we look very carefully the king is
all out of squares we can give queen g7
checkmate in that case
notice the queen and the knight working
together so the king has to go back to
ga just to remind you we're calculating
takes takes
knight g5 checking g8 then we can give a
check on g6 with the queen and we've got
a very classic mating scenario
if he goes to f8 queen f7 mate if he
goes to h8 then knight f7 mate
so either the knight is sort of the
supporting actor
um dangling the queen in front of black
screen like a marionette or the knight
itself
the rules are reversed the knight is the
checkmating piece the queen is the
restricting piece
um in either case i think that's a
pattern most of you will be familiar
with we can go ahead and execute these
moves notice what i said at the start
actually comes true we can sacrifice one
of the attackers
and we've got enough pieces left over to
where they are capable of then
finishing the job and we have yet
another position where
it's very clear at the outset that both
kings are getting
attacked we've got queen knight and
bishop as in the last problem here
involved in the attack and we are down a
rook so preliminarily it seems to me
that
the goal for black is going to be to
avoid the checks and there's going to be
enough pieces there
to give checkmate i should also point
out the queen is under fire so it would
be great if we could move the king onto
a square such that the queen cannot move
the problem is that's not possible we
have two moves king e6 king d6
and against both moves the queen can
capture on a6 with chuck
so you know in these situations when
you've got two
possible moves it's important to use the
method of comparison and try to
understand
rather than going very very deeply down
one of the moves we can try to kind of
look at both simultaneously
and figure out you know the similarities
and differences between them and maybe
we can figure out
that one of them has a very clear
drawback so let's start with gig e6
well probably black white's going to
take on a6 with check
and then we have to block with our
bishop and immediately i see a big
drawback this bishop on c5
is an integral part of black's attack
because it's restricting the king's
access to g1
and um if white goes h3 to defend
against me there's a very typical idea
where black then goes queen g3
threatening checkmate
forcing white to take the knight and
much like in our first problem the queen
then drops back to h4 with the h file
being
opened it is then checkmate but with the
bishop being on d6
the king then can just go to g1 so from
an attacking perspective that seems
uh like a very big concession so let's
move on to king d6
then if queen takes a6 we actually can
block with the other bishop the other
bishop is not
integral to the attack so at least from
that
point of view it seems to me that king
d6 is the move now there's just no case
to be made for king e6
in addition after king d6 white has no
checks other than
queen takes a6 after king e6 he's got
another chakra
that we have to reckon with knight c7 so
we're gonna safely make this move and
safely make this move
and that okay bishop f4 so he's
defending against mate
well we can give a check on f2 but
that's useless he's just gonna sacrifice
in exchange for that
so we have to take the bishop and our
task of avoiding the checks continues
he's given us e5 check
rather than getting overwhelmed once
again we just got to go through one by
one the possible king retreats and
figure out figure out
which one is best now my instinct is to
move the king back to d7 but i
immediately see that he's got a just a
deadly check on f5 with a bishop
that doesn't look like any good although
maybe we should extend that calculation
but
again um i want to make it very clear
that it's
it's important to use i think the
the analog in computer science is like
breadth first search rather than depth
first search rather than try to go too
deeply down one line
we look at a lot of them superficially
to try to figure out if we can rule any
of them out
you know sort of prune our decision tree
and that makes the situ
the decision itself a little bit less
overwhelming so let's now look at king
takes e5
okay well white has only one check right
rookie one check
and there my first instinct would be to
block the check so let's say we go
bishop e3 to preserve this very
important knight on g4
then if he goes rook takes e3
well it looks like we go f takes e3 and
it looks like we've escaped the checks
although wait a minute he's got rook f5
check there
oh gosh and the attack continues okay so
let's put that aside for a second
king e5 is very promising let's see if
we can't find anything simpler
what if we take the knight first well
then he's got two checks right he can
give us a check with c4 bishop
if he gives a bishop e4 check well then
we take on e5
and we use the bishop on e4 as an
umbrella to cover our king against the
check on the e-file
okay that leaves him with with c4 check
well
using the method of comparison we see
that if we take on e5
then it's basically the same position
except he's lacking a knight
surely that's got to be better than
taking on e5 immediately and don't call
me shirley but
the other thing i noticed is after king
d5 he's got bishop's c4 check but again
we can take on e5 and block on e3
and um that seems to be quite a bit
better than taking immediately i would
also point out king e6
allows queen takes c6 check and it's
very important if you have these five or
six possible moves
that you give all of them a little bit a
little bit of attention because
you might fall in love with one move and
then just forget that there's another
move that just ends the problems
immediately but here we see that that is
not the case
boom boom problem solved okay
so another got a lot of attacking theme
problems here so again the king
is very very weak it seems that queen
takes d5 immediate move that we should
start by considering
now queen takes d5 if the king moves to
e7 or eighth and mate is
very elementary queen f7 the issue is
queen takes d5 bishop d6
and these situations as i explained in
the previous problem
rather than get overwhelmed and try to
think your way to the solution you just
start looking at moves and
in this case you start looking at checks
because you're down two pieces you've
got a very narrow margin to make
something happen
okay so queen takes e5 bishop d6
if queen f7 check we can toss that out
immediately because he can block the
check with
his queen and bring another defender and
so
logically speaking if you do want to use
logic the ideal check would be something
that he cannot block
and that would essentially mean diagonal
checks so that's queen e6 check and
queen f5 check let's take a look at
queen f5 check
first for no particular reason again if
he moves to e7 or e8s
well we got to check me which means he's
got to move to c6 this is again after
takes d5
bishop d6 queen f5 check king c6
well then we have queen b5 checkmate
right and how did i see queen b5 well i
just looked at all of the potential
checking scores i see the king is out of
squares
other than d7 can we give a check to
block the king's movement to d7
well indeed we can so we can go ahead
and execute those moves so no rocket
science here
it's just a matter of going through as
many moves as possible
okay on to the next one
so apologies for my horse advice i've
been doing a lot of talking today
now here it seems again the contours of
the problem are very clear
black is up three pawns he's got a
passer on a2 we need to check my blocks
gain
somehow using the limited resources
available at our disposal
so let's reason logically right how many
squares does the king have
because there's two ways of delivering
checkmate we can either disrupt the
mechanism
or not we can either make the king on f3
or we can shift the king to a different
square and mate him
there which is of course much harder so
we should start by asking ourselves if
we cannot
simply checkmate the king where it is
well the king really has only one square
f4
so ideally we would deliver checkmate
from the f file but if we do it from any
square other than
f2 the king will have the e2 square so
the next question is can we deliver mate
on
f2 with this rook well immediate
obviously not immediately he just takes
but can we prepare that move well we
sure can we can go rook g2
we don't care if he makes a queen or a
zebra or a purple tiger
we're gonna mate him on f2 on the next
move he simply has no checks
boom boom problem solved ladies and
gentlemen
well it's only been 15 minutes let's do
one last one
and a very interesting problem this is
so what's going on here a queen is under
fire
i'll take another sip of water here
hopefully i can
have enough voice left to talk through
this final problem
okay so our queen is under fire but
immediately we notice that
we can take the bishop right we can take
the bishop on c2 what's his idea
well our king is weak so his idea is
clearly to go queen f6
and made us and a lot of people would
just toss that out there and say ah
that's not possible
but i like to take a couple more seconds
i call this the 15 second rule when
you're in a position and you're about to
stop calculating
force yourself to take 15 more seconds
and see if you can't override
that instinct to panic because a move
looks particular
particularly intimidating so what i see
after queen takes c2 queen f6 is that
i can try to intercept that battery
and i can do that in several ways i can
put something on e5 but that gives up
the piece and
you know white's gonna end up with a
beautiful connected protected passer on
c5
i can go e5 but notice that the queen on
f6 can then capture the knight but i can
also go d4
and d4 only gives up a pawn if he takes
with the bishop then
i take the sting out of everything by
taking the bishop if he takes with a
pawn
well i have a tempo and i can use this
tempo to swing my queen
from c2 to f5 dislodging white's queen
from f6
and ending up with an extra piece so we
can safely go ahead and do this
yeah he takes with the bishop we take
back and the problem is salter let's
keep going
so here we're down a rook okay
and not only are we down a rook black is
threatening checkmate on b1 so there's a
lot of factors that
basically can tell us that we need to
operate a by giving checks and b it's
clear that
it seems clear to me that the only
solution here is to somehow deliver
checkmate to black's king
now there's only one feasible check we
can give a check on f7 with the knight
but he's just going to take and as i
mentioned before
you're solving these problems in order
to get better at real games so if you
see a move and you know it's the only
move
you don't need to sit there and try to
calculate everything out until the end
okay you can go ahead and play it okay
again let's take a look at all the
checks well f8 queen
promotes but it doesn't help because
we've already noticed black's threat
notice
how important it is here to first
understand your opponent's threats it
can allow you to rule out a lot of
tempting moves
i see also a check on h8 but basically
that repeats the whole problem you just
give up one queen you make another but
after king h7
the queen is tied to the knight on h6
which black will take in the event of
any check
okay is there any other checks well
there is a check right we can make a
knight
we can make a knight we can under
promote and if we make a knight
we send the king further down to h6 then
we can give him another check from
okay okay let's calculate the king has
to go to g5
now that queen from h can travel then to
h4
delivering a check and stopping the king
from escaping to f6
the king has to go to f5 this is a great
time to make these moves on your board
okay now let's think about that position
let's visualize it how do we visualize
it
we ask ourselves again what are the
king's possible escape squares we notice
that the knight on f8 defends e6
g6 is blocked by blackstone pawn so that
leaves us with e5
and that's it if we can give a check
with the queen
to keep all three of these squares under
control it's going to be checkmate
and such a square exists right f4 f4 is
a square
that keeps these squares under control
and
white's knight and black's pawn does the
rest
boom boom and the problem
has been solved all right let's do one
last one folks
before my voice permanently disappears
okay a situation where both queens are
hanging i love these problems
these problems are generally easier than
they seem when both queens are hanging
the first thing you look for is what's
called a desperado sacrifice a desperado
sacrifice
is a sacrifice well where you give up
your queen for as much as you could give
it for
with the knowledge that you're then
going to take your opponent's queen
and have that extra whatever it is you
got
now that means we need to look at every
capture right
first capture on d5 no not good because
white's queen captures
and black ends up losing the exchange
the jokes on him
okay so we can take here but white takes
back okay right so
he not only we got to be careful about
that a lot of people forget about that
they try a desperado sacrifice and they
forget that their opponent's queen can
actually
take that piece and take their and take
the queen at the same time
so what else is there we can take the
rook promising
the queen cannot take d1 we attack the
other rook so
what has to attend to that he's got to
take
and then we take the queen problem
solved boom
boom and we ladies and gentlemen are up
a rook
so that was eight problems that we just
knocked down
now i will say that sometimes when
you're solving problems in this
raiding neighborhood you get an
occasional problem that's incredibly
difficult
and even i have some problems with them
pun intended get it
but by and large you can still use logic
and if your visualization is decent
and you're able to calculate four or
five moves ahead
and you're able to visualize the
position you can use this logic and you
can ask the right questions
and understand the sort of decision
logic that you use to solve each of
these problems and remember a lot of
them
you simply need to plunge in and get
your hands dirty you sort of need to
start looking at moves if you have three
or four
king escapes rather than sitting there
and panicking
you use the method of comparison and you
just start looking at moves because
sometimes if you compare one move in
another move you reach a key
insight if you had made the appropriate
observations at the beginning
um that will then allow you to maybe
even take some shortcuts and and not
calculate everything to the end also
remember breadth
first search not depth first search
sometimes you want to look at a couple
of moves superficially
and again figure out how they're
different rather than going too deeply
down one move
and taking 30 minutes and getting
frustrated when the solution
just you know laid two moves deep in
another move
so i hope you folks enjoyed um i might
do
a follow-up video where i do more
problems in this rating range i might go
a little bit higher or lower
based on the feedback remember i
appreciate all feedback whether it's
positive whether it's constructive
criticism
i want this channel to be the best that
it can be
and i want every every video to benefit
as many players
as i can um so i hope you guys enjoyed i
apologize for my slightly hoarse voice
today
it's been a long day uh but i hope you
enjoyed this video
feel free to leave comments and
questions
and um if you enjoyed the content i
would very much appreciate it if you
subscribed
in any case i will see you in the next
video i'll be doing more
problems and uh the next opening video
uh on naredinsky's gambit refutations
busting the gamuts
will appear very shortly as well thank
you very much
and see you in the next video